good afternoon everyone
i'm dr miller and the scp we're going to
be looking at today
is scp-5167
object class ketter
special containment procedures
foundation web crawlers are to monitor
online communities for mentions of
potential scp-5167
sightings in cases where these sightings
are confirmed all direct witnesses are
to be apprehended
and all secondary evidence removed from
the platform in question
apprehended witnesses are to be held
until symptoms of scp-5167 abate
and are then to be amnesticized and
released under a standard mental
breakdown cover story
description scp-5167 is an entity known
to manifest as a player of the online
multiplayer game
among us under the username of thonas
scp-5167 will randomly join multiplayer
lobbies of the game
and participate as an ordinary player
would with the majority of its anomalous
effects
only becoming obvious following the
initial encounter
during this initial encounter scp-5167
has been observed to communicate using
the in-game chat function
although the majority of its speech
consists of lengthy diatribes produced
at little prompting from other players
individuals who interact with scp-5167
in game
will subsequently begin to exhibit
symptoms of paranoia
and copterous delusion a psychiatric
disorder in which an individual comes to
believe that those around them have been
replaced with identical impostors
the severity of these symptoms varies
from person to person
but in initial cases was significant
enough to prompt acts of perceived
self-defense
from those affected full record of
recorded scp-5167-related homicides
available in the site-22 archives
these symptoms persist for a period
initially believed to encompass several
months
but has lessened to one or two weeks as
observation has continued
scp-5167 was initially discovered by the
foundation
after a period during which the player
thonus was a minor urban legend in the
among us community
although interest in the figure died
down fairly quickly
foundation web crawlers flagged recorded
accounts of player encounters with the
entity
as potential anomalous phenomena
learning computer sci-2
mevel was assigned to track sessions of
the game
until scp-5167 was encountered
and when the other players in said
session were tracked down
they exhibited symptoms now associated
with scp-5167
foundation efforts to track the
individual behind scp-5167
have thus far proven unsuccessful
all attempts to locate the internet
access point used by the anomaly
have led to deserted home addresses in
rural
greece analysis of impending scp-5167
neutralization
as requested by head researcher abrams
i've had the site 22 analysts look into
the progress of scp-5167's anomalous
effects
over the period we've observed it and
the results are
much as i expected when we first
discovered a cp5167
for the sake of argument let's say this
is when scp-5167
first came into existence the impact it
had
on its victims was severe i don't think
i have to remind you of what billy hef
did to his family's faces
but since then almost immediately really
since that first couple of
manifestations
the potency of its effects has started
to decline
full detachment from reality became
delusion
and delusion has now become paranoia and
the intensity of that paranoia
is lessening in each new case this is
all conjecture of course
and shouldn't be taken as gospel but
based on what we've observed of this
anomaly so far
our estimation is that scp-5167's
anomalous effects will become inert
by the end of the year whether it'll
keep popping up in these video game
matches
is another story though site 22
intelligence director
michael ross observation log
5167 want
the following is a log of scp-5167 as
observed by learning computers psi
2 in a game of among us scp-5167
participated in the game without
communicating
until specifically addressed by other
players
following the game all participating
players were tracked down and treated
as containment procedures dictate
playing log now
red where were you when we were doing
reactor
where was i i was there
when the mountains were newborn and the
ocean's
virginal i was there when gods
walked among men and their wisdom was
cast down
like sunlight i was there when mankind
was capable of legends
and now i find myself
in a world that has forgotten even the
taste of life
even the very concept of life beyond
existing
from one day to the mere next
where all the world is wasted away in
idle play of emotions that once
rang true i am in a world where even the
gods
are forgotten their bones washed away by
time
a world where man has moved on where all
the legacy i have left are three
sentences on wikipedia
i thought my time had come again
i thought this could be the new me
but this is nothing
let me stay dead this time
i'm tired
[Music]
red
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are
and you're all dismissed goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
onyx arbiter soul
the morrigan retalias
karim el ashmuy patrick bailey
dreams boy that in right
matthew gilmore eric corbich
kauai fire keeper joker corvus
king madding james saba
and nj vojak if you would like a special
thank you at the end of each of my
videos
and some other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash the vogue thank you
you